eleven states are set to start using
coronavirus restrictions tomorrow as
protests ramped up throughout the
country over lockdown orders many
Americans hitting the streets this
weekend to put pressures on their
governors demanding to let them get back
to work and so now we want to bring in
the former governor of Arkansas and Fox
News contributor Mike Huckabee governor
Huckabee good morning to you what are
your thoughts this morning on that well
I think governor's across the country
are recognizing that people have had
about enough of just being told to stay
home don't go anywhere don't do anything
everybody wants to be safe people have
applied extraordinary measures to
protect themselves and their friends and
their neighbors but there's also a point
at which we cannot live hunkered down
forever it's not like bombs are dropping
on top of London we're at a time when
we've got to get back to work or there's
not going to be anything to get out of
the house to go back to so increasingly
governors are ramping up and it's
interesting to note Brian Kemp in
Georgia is a good example people were
just hammering him for starting to open
back up but his state is seen the lowest
number of Kovan 19 cases now since this
whole thing started
Ron DeSantis in Florida where I am right
now he was getting hammered he wasn't
doing enough but the truth is Florida
has a bigger population than New York
more senior population than New York and
a small fraction of the number of cases
so these governors who have managed by
saying let's not shut everything down
too quickly
have actually had far better results
than the ones who closed the doors
locked the key and started arresting
people for doing such things as getting
a haircut or buying seeds to plant
tomatoes in their garden yeah I mean 60
percent of the cases in New York came
from people at home as well is there is
there a perverse incentive in some cases
for for politicians to sort of move the
goalposts and continue to keep it locked
down to say hey because say we're gonna
prevent every single death we can of
course we want to do that but it seems
like there's a political incentive to do
that too well there may be a political
incentive you know there's certainly a
power grab that I find
revolting we don't live in a police
state I've been all over the world I've
been as you have Pete to some places
that are authoritarian totalitarian
governments and every time I'm there I'm
thinking I want to get out of here this
is not America I like freedom and and I
visited some police states I don't want
to live in one and I think one thing we
are beginning to recognize is that part
of the reason this is extended is
because all the government people who
are telling us to lock our doors and not
go anywhere they're all getting their
paychecks every last one of them not one
government employee is failing to get
their paycheck so if we really want to
solve this let's say this if you're a
government person and you're telling
other people they can't get their pay
you don't get yours and that includes
Nancy Pelosi and the members of Congress
governor part of what impresses me so
much about you is your ability to
articulate so simply and clearly
solutions and that's probably what I
loved about your book simple government
and so I wanted to get your thoughts on
the USS relationship with China right
because we're sparring with China right
now over many things and we have for so
long and right now we're sparring with
them over the pro who language and UN
Security Council pandemic ceasefire
resolution language and Beijing wanted
to mention the whose role in tackling
the virus and the resolution while we
have demanded more critical language
what is your solution that you recommend
what are your thoughts on how we can
disentangle ourselves from China's grip
well it great question because that's
exactly what it is China's grip this
started when a lot of American
multinational globalist countries
decided they could make a real quick
buck by shipping all the manufacturing
that we used to do here to China we're
cheap labor would do it without any
regard whatsoever for the environment or
for human rights abuses so we did that
and we had cheap stuff but now we're
seeing that cheap stuff under the iron
hand of communism isn't cheap at all
it's like pay me now pay me later well
we're paying boy are we ever paying for
all of the things that we sold out to
China and frankly the way that the World
Health Organization who has kowtow to
China is disgusting and revolting in the
press
Trump is exactly right to do what he's
done let me just say this I've got more
confidence in the rock band who than I
have chance to share your Mother's Day
thoughts well happy Mother's Day to all
the moms my own mother has been deceased
for a number of years I've got a photo
of her but not one with me because she
refused to be seen with me in public
from the time I was a tot but I also you
know have a wonderful wife who's mother
to our three children and a wonderful
grandmother to her six grandchildren
she's recovering from a broken ankle in
three places she stepped on a grand
child's toy this past week facing
surgery tomorrow saw her mother's day is
a little more painful than it ought to
be oh goodness
poisel kitchen governor we hope she
recovers quickly governor thank you so
much thank you thank you see you